sometimes there are times in life that
make us realize how lucky we are and how
special our lives are as difficult as it
may be to see this now this is one of
those times America is different today
than it was even last week we are facing
an incredibly contagious and dangerous
virus that is moving across the world
from one hotspot to another
as a result America is changing how we
operate more often than not at a slower
pace it's something we're just not used
to we're Americans we move fast we come
and go as we please
and we interact with whomever wherever
and whenever we want well not anymore
yeah it's a freakishly abnormal shutdown
it's a pain all of us are affected I've
changed my daily routine just like many
of you have and I'm miserable like many
of you probably are everything has
changed or stopped March Madness to the
Masters from kindergarten to college
students being sent home to weddings and
events being canceled airports closed or
limited churches synagogues concerts
closed or limited Broadway gone dark all
the news is dispiriting but we're
Americans born of a revolution rugged
and resourceful and resolute our
determination and our perseverance are
hallmarks of who we are and from whence
we came it's in our DNA
so we batten down the hatches during
this period until life returns to normal
we learn and practice sacrifice as our
families have over generations the ones
who came here to enjoy the fruits of the
greatest nation on earth
we will now practice social distancing
ultimately no large crowds no touching
no hugging it leads to spending more
time alone as experts hope to flatten
the inevitable curve of the virus this
will take discipline and self-control we
simply have to buckle up and tough it
out
and in maybe six months hopefully look
back at this it's just a blip on the
screen of life so how to do that stay
busy and keep calm I've watched people
panicking in a supermarket but panic is
a waste of energy and it's exhausting
focus instead on what you have to offer
this is the time for kindness and grace
and generosity are their senior citizens
that you know who can't get to a grocery
store or who could use a home-cooked
meal which are probably making more of
anyway these days and you must be
informed about this virus you cannot be
complacent you may be young and your
children may be even younger and while
children don't seem to be affected kids
can be carriers who would just a simple
hug or kiss to Grandma or anyone older
can pass something that may be harmless
to the child but lethal to the older
person pitch in it'll make you feel
better
we saw it just yesterday as the Giants
and private sectors stepped up with the
president Walmart Walgreens CVS and many
more to help us get through this even
though they know they're going to take a
big financial it like them we need to be
strong enough to know what we face and
strong enough to understand what we need
to do about it as the experts continue
their mission to fight this epidemic I
wonder how many of us will use this time
to examine our lives and assess what
really is important one minute we're
enjoying the bounties of life and then
like a thunderbolt
our lives are suddenly changed maybe
just maybe we are blessed with a time
for introspection my introspection is
informed by my belief in God take this
time to decide what's important to you